on a les notes alors vous votre note
benjamin castaldi
moi j'ai mis cette jeunesse que je suis
fan de chabat il très drôles j'adore en
tant que comédien il est très bon dans
ce registre là après phénomène éphémère
certainement parce que je pense que plus
on envoie et plus on se lasse un peu
comme pas mal de jeu il n'y a pas deux
c'est très dur il n'y a pas de
continuité voilà rissman c'est compliqué
en plus hier soir le casting était pas
formidables fans ne soient pas en plus
aimés sympa mais c'est pas un fort cassé
en revanche moi je suis fan du
personnage et c'est vrai que c'est un
jeu qui m'a marqué il ya donc avec nous
disant et voilà j'aime beaucoup
bon vous allez me cette maxime gagné 4
ou la balade sur 10 ouais je vous
expliquer pourquoi
concernant l'émission dire oui sur une
île vient de parler on dirait qu'il est
une mauvaise note il veut efficace
expliqué pourquoi pas alors ils ont été
surclassés les états unis tu vois je me
dans la gueule césar est sûre dit ce que
force est de constater il y a évidemment
un casting moins puissantes que les
dernières fois ça joue évidemment sur
l'envergure du programme une redondance
des vannes moi j'étais très content de
le retrouver ce programme est là si vous
m'aviez posé la question il ya quelques
semaines jérémy aller à sept sur dix
pensent que ça a réveillé en moi de la
nostalgie
c'est comme si je retrouvais une ex que
j'ai perdu depuis dix ans je suis
content la retrouver mais j'ai pas envie
de construire avec elle et vous avez des
ex il a dégénéré
voyez mais voilà l'explication alors il
nous a dit il il est sorti avec 9,9
savons pas il nous l'a dit à la fois
dans la saison et après plus rien maxime
on respecte maxime se calent attention
de daniel bon on devrait regarder la
télé ensemble parce que j'ai à peu près
le même avis j'aime ici c'est très
bientôt son ex en tout cas c'est vrai
que il y avait il faut dire que ça a
commencé fort 2 millions de la première
il y avait une énorme attend les braxois
6,2 millions doit ces voix-là almées
mais c'est normal c'était vraiment la
petite madeleine de proust il ya eu
l'effet nostalgie
a u moi je pense qu'il faudrait que ça
soit événementiel c'est à dire des
petites séries avec les stars parce que
quand on passe comme vous dites de
vanessa paradis à ceux qui étaient hier
qu'ils étaient très bien mais ma mère
honnêtement non connaissez aucun des
quatre donc c'est quand même mauvais
c'est la 4e 20 septembre
condé filon les gens parce que ma mère
allait aller vraiment rock'n'roll un
sofa koné youssouf un bon peut-être pas
quand même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces personnes dont il ya ça y est filmée
puis moi j'adore chabat et tout ça mais
voilà vannes un petit peu redondante
l'effet surprise est fini je me suis
ennuyé en général je quand je m'ennuie
c'est mauvais signe
et voilà ils ont vraiment beaucoup
baissé et valenciennes se serait bien
merci
le fait que vous ayez été sincèrement
heureuse et vous savez que vous passez
pas de la pommade ne pense pas que le
fait d'avoir été dans strike avec la
guerre tu as contribué à faire monter ce
trac et du coup baissé un peu le burger
c'est possible
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
après ça c'est difficile moi j'ai mis
six parce que c'est décevant en force
cette émission est extrêmement clivante
si vous voulez ça s'adresse pas à tout
le monde
non c'est vraiment que c'est très
parisien je trouve je suis sûr qu'on
province les gens ne regardent pas donc
voilà on est déçu c'est fini maintenant
effectivement sûr d'y être événementiel
malgré la qualité je trouve des invités
qui sont très sympas et de gros
tracteurs et et chabail formidable mais
là c'est trop entre soi quoi c'est
clivant alors bien sûr tout vous
derrière les réactions n'étaient pas
très bonnes bon apparemment astronautes
qui regarde aileurs doc oui j'ai pas
compris pourquoi tout le monde rigolait
j'ai pas vu un seul moment drôle
pourtant je suis bon public
bon je viens d'animer je comprends pas
grand chose on peut m'expliquer s'il
vous plaît gilles verdez mollo l'asticot
gmi 0 j'ai cherché par tous les moyens à
trouver ou mettre un point mais c'est
pas possible
une émission du passé c'est une émission
qui flirte effectivement pour la
nostalgie de bobos parisiens qui se
souviennent de bons moments mais y'en a
plus de bons moments le casting était
mauvais les blacks sont pas drôles
chabat c'est toujours la même chose ils
parlent entre eux c'est totalement exclu
en franchement qu'il fasse une émission
de leur côté mais sans la diffuser quand
on a vu la photo de lui petit tout c'est
que le gars il vénère d'entrée de jeu ce
qu'on peut être invité dans burger quiz
vous savez fait précédemment je crois
que lors des éditions précédentes ce que
vous seriez très beau mais je crois que
c'est bien la rareté moi je suis
d'accord je crois n'a pas revu mais je
crois que c'est bien là ça c'est parce
que l' issue mais je vais vous dire
forcément ils sont obligés de le faire
toutes les semaines
c'est vrai qu'ils ont ils perdu je vous
dis purée de 10 points sur les ménages
et un rôti bas mais ça reste toujours
des scores très très correct il faut le
dire
alors les chéris on va voir tiens on va
voir ce qu'on pense les téléspectateurs
burger 50/50 voyait non caniveau qui
s'était pas votre poids votre trio
génération va c'est pas ben je pense pas
que ce soit ma génération parce que je
suis jamais tombé dessus est en plus
jeunes
donc du coup par curiosité j'ai un petit
peu regardé parce que les gens en
parlait justement pour regarder le
retour de burger quiz et c'est vrai que
bah ça va pas être mon c'est peut-être
que pour les anciens au final parce que
moi qui ai nouvelle téléspectatrices jeu
ça me fait pas rire et je me suis
vachement nuit et ce truc il a manqué de
rythme en fait c'est vers ça sinon
l'avenir mais c'est ça voilà ce qui m'a
marqué alors